[Music]
Atlantic cult there's a situation back
in the states where you're kidding
how long has it been since your home
well my name is dr. Abby arcane my team
is here to find the source of this
disease you saw a party dealt with
anything like that before
who are you again Pollard Alec Colin was
investigating illegal dumping on this
swamp dr. Jason would ruin a seedy
season too there's no way that my
accelerant is responsible
there's this poison coming off a small
there's been a shift in the balance of
the life in the dark
something south we're dealing with
something beyond the known scope of
science
I made it alive stuck there is all kinds
of awful that happens in this one
there's something special about this
place there's so much of a magical
beauty out there happy
[Music]
hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my first swampthing video I've had a
chance to see the first couple of
episodes so I'll do a review
obviously they just dropped a full
trailer so you have a good idea for what
some of the characters look like before
they turn because some of the people you
see in this trailer as people eventually
mutate into big characters from the
comics episode 1 drops on Friday so
that's when you'll be able to watch it
obviously it's on the DC streaming
service so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the DC easter-egg videos we'll do a new
round of the giveaway for that DC comic
service all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a swamp thing
comment on the video so a big thing
first obviously the first couple of
episodes just do a lot of world-building
explaining who the characters are main
character obviously Alec Holland in
Swamp Thing and Abbie arcane who you
probably recognize as crystal Reed from
Teen Wolf in a whole bunch other stuff
you probably recognize her from
somewhere if you didn't watch Teen Wolf
for the most part you enter the story
through her perspective because remember
once Swamp Thing becomes Swamp Thing he
doesn't talk a whole lot he's like the
huge monster so a lot of the series in
the world-building you get through her
eyes through her perspective when the
series picks up she's in a third world
country with the CDC trying to help get
rid of a local disease help the local
populace so we just let you know what
her personality is like she's fearless
she's a doctor with a specialty in
infectious diseases so she's obviously
very smart but she's also a stone-cold
Fox
you don't meet Alec Hall until a little
bit later but obviously you meet Alec
Hall and the doctor before you meet the
swampthing monster so they give you the
pleasure of watching him turn into Swamp
Thing and they don't drag it on for too
long before they get to actual Swamp
Thing stuff going on when the series
picks up like you see at the beginning
of this trailer here you actually start
with this little girl who starts
coughing up this green fluid that is not
blood I know that kind of looks like
blood in the trailer the town where this
is all happening on the swamp on the
Bayou is where she grew up as a child so
she has childhood connections to a lot
of these big characters she has a really
dark past that you slowly learn about
over the first couple of episodes so
there's a little bit of conflict when
she first comes back but the CDC sends
her back after you see this little girl
start convulsing and spewing out all
this green fluid that they think becomes
this big infectious disease going around
the swamp
Lenard name who you probably recognize
from about
of other stuff he was just on Westworld
season one in season two but he's with
her in the CDC so that's why he's also
here he's supposed to be playing a big
character but he's not a comic book
character so I don't know exactly how
they're gonna be using him later in the
series them inside the church here
happens relatively early it's them
addressing the issue of a potential
disease going around the swamp that's
where you meet the main antagonist Avery
Sutherland who you probably recognize
his will Patton he's been in a whole
bunch of really big movies he just looks
a little bit older on this series his
character is a really big Swamp Thing
villain from the classic comics they are
going way back to Alan Moore's Swamp
Thing which is why a lot of people are
like will Constantine eventually guest
star on the series because in the
episodes I've seen so far they have
introduced a lot of supernatural ideas
and characters with supernatural
abilities so maybe in the future if they
can get access to that character but
right now I think he's still in the CW
DC TV universe which because of some
complicated rights issues is kind of
often its own separate thing so I don't
think there's a looking to cross over
those universes any time soon the DC TV
universe in the Titans universe over on
the DC streaming service I wasn't really
familiar with the actor playing Alec
Holland before this but he's relatively
charming we've really just waiting for
him to turn into Swamp Thing so we can
start doing really cool crazy stuff from
the comics but they do a fairly good job
of establishing a rapport between him
and Abby arcane because they're supposed
to be the big romance on the show so
right now just based on the few episodes
I've seen it's not really clear how Andy
being the actor who's playing the human
Alec Holland is going to be involved in
future episodes after he becomes Swamp
Thing this scene of him kissing Abby
talking to her at night while she's in
her bed is from an episode that I have
not seen yet so I'm assuming that either
there's gonna be some really crazy
supernatural stuff that will make him
seem human that will allow him to
interact with her as a human when he's
not Swamp Thing or they'll have some
really crazy psychedelic way of
explaining it they do a pretty good job
of explaining the supernatural and
scientific aspects of how all these
things work within the universe of these
comic book shows the biggest new thing
that they introduce is the idea of
mutagens
so you think mutants you think Fox
Marvel Marvel Universe but a lot of his
biggest villains from the comics are
people that were turned into monsters
through mutation so you probably
recognize kevin durand from
a bunch of other stuff he's playing the
floor on ik man he sort of like the mid
bad so Avery Solo and this is sort of
like the biggest villain on the show but
he's more of a corporate sinister evil
rich guy type of villain
Florin ik man is probably going to be
one of the punch you in the face kind of
villains that swampthing himself in
Swamp Thing form will wind up fighting
by the end of the series this green
looking serum as you would expect is a
lot of the catalyst for the changes that
mutate people into these monsters and is
mutating the swamp so that it becomes
alive within the first couple of
episodes though you do learn that it's
not just Swamp Thing controlling
everything within the swamp the swamp
itself is sort of like a character on
the show
because of all these mutations if you're
a big fan of horror this is meant to be
the first DC comics legit horror series
they're pushing rated-r but I wouldn't
call it hard are if you've seen any Doom
Patrol episodes I would say that it's a
little more hardcore than that but
because it's not on broadcast networks
they can show as much blood as they want
they can be as violent as they want so
they do have a little bit more fun than
you would see during the DC TV shows
this is another more hardcore clip
that'll give you a better sense for that
if you miss dr. okay Americain 5000
people work at the CDC
it's 4999 other options they could have
sent there's all kinds of awful that
happens in this swamp but I think you'd
know that she was like my sister it's
like held her all that darkness wasn't
my fault
he was yours
nice outfit
so speaking of really freaky
supernatural stuff blue devil is a
character on the show
this is an early shot of him I don't
know what he fully looks like in his
costume once he becomes blue devil but
his human form is played by Ian ziering
the first time I heard that I was like
wait a minute what's going on with that
that seems kind of weird but he actually
appears within the first couple of
episodes he does a pretty legit good job
with the material but I have not seen
him turn into blue devil on the show yet
so this clip of him in the trailer is
from a future episode but the way they
explain his character because he is a
supernatural character who is an actual
blue devil but he starts out as an actor
in real life who's known for playing a
blue devil character so he wears a
costume in all the movies that he
appears then eventually the costume gets
grafted to his skin and he's possessed
by a demon so he becomes the literal
blue devil I've only seen the actor
version of blue devil before he actually
becomes the real devil so we'll find out
about that in future episodes you're
probably at least a little familiar with
Madame Xanadu on the TV show she does
actually have legit magical powers she
has the ability to talk to the dead and
she's really good at reading people's
futures using the tarot cards
she might have other abilities too but
I've only seen the first couple of
episodes so we haven't seen a whole lot
from her character yet but when you see
a lot of dead people walking around in
the trailer here then getting really
horror with it a lot of the really
sinister supernatural stuff is where she
comes into the story Virginia Madsen is
playing the wife of Avery Sutherland
like you see her trying to choke a br
cane out in the swamp here I don't know
if this is legit her or this is a
hallucination that Abby is having while
she's in the swamp
she and Abby have really crazy history
because it's something really bad that
happened with Abby's childhood friend
who was her daughter who wound up dying
so because of all this crazy biological
agents the mutagens they start tripping
balls and people who are loosen ating
stuff all over the place in the first
couple of episodes so if you remember
the Swamp Thing movies those got a
little campy this actually treats the
material way more seriously and they are
really trying to go back to those
classic alan moore comics but as far as
i know they're not planning on big
crossovers with Titans or Doom Patrol or
anything like that I think at least the
first season it's only ten episodes is
just going to be relatively
self-contained
to what's going on in around the Bayou
here there's a lot of funny stuff that
we could talk
in terms of Swamp things relationship
with a be arcane because they do have a
romance in the comics but practically
that doesn't work because Swamp Thing
isn't a man the really crazy thing about
The Swamp Thing character if you're not
a big comic book reader is that a lot of
people mistakenly think that alec
holland is mutated into Swamp Thing when
really what Swamp Thing is is that
really he's sort of an amalgam that the
swamp creates of a biological creature
with the memories absorbed from Alec
Holland's body so he's not literally
Alec Holland walking around in giant
plant form he's a giant plan with the
memories of Alec Holland so like I said
they haven't completely explained how
they're gonna continue to use the Andy
being human form Alec Holland in future
episodes after he becomes Swamp Thing so
I'm assuming at least a little bit of
the series will be dedicated to dealing
with the idea of are you really you if
you're just your memories in someone
else's body will he think of himself as
Alec Colin going forward because he
definitely doesn't understand what's
going on when he first becomes Swamp
Thing he still thinks of himself as
human like why am I covered in all this
green goo what's going on once you have
a chance to see it let me know what you
think of it in the comments below and
I'll just do more Swamp Thing videos
based on the interest level from all you
guys on my channel so if a whole bunch
of people watch this video and you guys
really want more Swamp Thing episode
videos then I'll keep doing more as the
series goes on don't forget we have Ian
Glen from Game of Thrones playing Batman
on Titan season two we have Deathstroke
Superboy so Titans will premiere this
fall we'll probably get a trailer for
that at Comic Con just like we did last
year as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you see all those videos
when they post so no worries while you
wait for everything
click here for my new Avengers endgame
deleted scene video and click here for
my brand new spider-man far from home
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]